There are a lot of new products out there, both supplements and topical, including peptides.
Do you know anything about them and whether they are helpful for cancer or particularly
more effective than other supplements taken for some ailment like glucose metabolism,
for example?
So peptides are the latest thing.
I think, you know, I do know that there's, I know, the Reordinate Clinic got into using peptides
and I think they kind of phased out of that.
There were really big, a couple years ago and injectable peptides are still big, but
they were really big a few years ago.
And there's dangers in that with cancer because it can stimulate growth.
Most of the peptides out there are for the purpose of stimulating growth.
So they're really used most commonly for athletic people and people that are in sports and
people that have athletic injuries.
So injectable peptides in joints and such to repair joints more quickly because they stimulate
growth.
Well, that's obviously a giant red flag when you come to cancer care, but I do know that
there are some different peptides that are available that don't do that.
And I'm just still really leery of the that because none of it's done specifically with cancer
in mind.
There really, it's really being pushed for other reasons.
So there's remember a lot of things that you would do for your heart or for muscle issues
or for repair of joint or for repair of the dot would be absolute donals for cancer.
So because a lot of those things the way they work is to stimulate regeneration of cell
lines, which is speed up metabolic pathways for growth, which can certainly help for cell
lines and things that will stimulate Vagyev production in your heart, vascular endothelial
growth factor to stimulate growth of vessels for cardiovascular issues, fantastic for heart
issues, really bad for cancer patients.
So that's where some people go, I'm going to my you know, I get this a lot with on case
reviews, you know, initial calls I have with people.
I feel like I'm really comfortable with the supplements that I'm taking for my naturopath
or my chiropractor or my doctor who you're my functional doctor, and then I look at them
and I go, you may want to reconsider this one, reconsider this one, reconsider this one.
You know, everything you learn in functional medicine, everything you learn in naturopath
the everything you learn in nutrition courses in a chiropractic, you know, education, do
not equate to what you would do if you have cancer.
So in many of them should be, you know, there's no way you should do with cancer, so so you
you just got to be careful with that, so, so I tried to, you know, I just put in my two
sense people couldn't throw it out and not listen to me, but on the case, we were just want
to help people whether they start with us or not is want to, you know, let them know the
reasoning behind things.
So I think peptides fall into that, I wouldn't do them.